hey guys Pete here it's going to be my
Game of Thrones Season seven episode 3
preview I've already done a trailer
breakdown with the frame-by-frame
earlier in the week so this is going to
be tied in with that but based primarily
on these new photos we got from episode
3 that which titled the Queen's Justice
there will be some spoilers here if you
don't want to see stuff that's going to
come up you won't want to watch but
other than that I'm not presenting
anything new
so let's mention the name of the episode
is the Queen's justice and it's
interesting because we don't know
exactly if they're talking about the
Queen who's sitting on the Iron Throne
or the Queen who has just arrived in
Dragonstone or both we know that this
episode is 63 minutes long which is
about nine minutes longer than the
average so it's so that's a good amount
of time to add when you think about how
fast things actually develop in an
episode of Game of Thrones the big thing
that they are pushing is that Jon Snow
is finally going to meet Daenerys
Targaryen we've seen that in the trailer
the SBCC trailer and now in these photos
that almost exclusively kind of focus on
that setup so start with this first
image that is John and Davos getting out
of a boat landing on the beach at
Dragonstone and the season premiere we
saw Daenerys land at this exact same
spot and with everything that's going on
I'm sure we're going to see a lot of
comings and goings from this landing
here John is dressed to impress with his
direwolf breastplate that we've seen in
a couple other shots and he looks the
part of king in the north
Davos looks like Davos usually does but
they both have this determined look on
their face then they realize the gravity
of the situation and it's pretty awesome
they arrive with a small escort so no
one else of note to mention behind them
there they're just guards one of the
things I really love about the Helen
Sloane photos she's beyond set
photographer that does all the stills
that we see in promotional materials and
one thing I really always loved about
them is the detail that you can make out
compared to like screenshots and stuff
that we see when we watch
in real-time so it stands out here the
most to me is John's clothing he has
officially come a long way from his days
as a brother of the Nights Watch we get
two shots of Musante and Tyrion who were
sent down to the beach to receive these
guys as of course you wouldn't expect
the Queen to be out there to meet them
in person again the details here are the
highlights and we get to see these two
close up and their get ups we've seen
this stuff in the filming photos that
came out earlier but they were all like
a mile away so this is really cool
actually
we see that both decked out Tyrion has
some new stripes and his hand is a clean
pin and Musante has a cool adornment
there was three dragon heads arranged in
the circle on her leather trim so team
House Targaryen came dressed to impress
their distinguished visitor from the
north because this is Tyrion we can
imagine there'll be a pretty good
conversation that will happen here he
stated that he likes John which we've
seen in their previous interactions and
those have all been quite some time ago
doll ghost and Tyrion on the other hand
should have some serious bad blood based
on what happened at the Battle of the
Blackwater if you remember Tyrion as the
one who unleashed wildfire on Stannis's
fleet there which in the show's version
of events killed Davos his son matthos
fun fact in the books that he actually
lost four sons at the Battle of
Blackwater Bay but that isn't really
important here Tyrion was responsible
for the death of his own his only son on
the show and this brings to mind that
even though most of our attention is on
Jon and Daenerys meeting some of the
other meetings are going to be like
maybe more interesting resting if you
think about it
in the trailer we saw Jon in Davos being
led to the throne room of dragon stones
awesome staircase there
in the sdcc trailer we see the shot of
all those dragons circling above the
castle so I've been wondering if John
and Davos will see those at you know see
them for the first time at that point we
have three actual pictures from inside
the throne room the one we've seen
already which is Davos and John looking
at the throne and the Queen for the
first time I mentioned John's look in
the trailer breakdown which looks like
all or possibly he's just uncertain in
his position so he's a little bit
overwhelmed either way he doesn't look
confident or set up in a way that he
feels comfortable which is what you'd
expect the Queen to do was put him in a
weird position so that she had the upper
hand
I mean we see that she's sitting on her
throne like a real Queen it's up higher
than he is so she asked you know so she
looks down he looks up definite definite
cool set up there it's our first
sighting of her wearing the Targaryen
colors if I'm not mistaken we see that
she has a red cape to go along with her
black dress then that's all pretty
exciting it looks like she has a dragon
team that drapes around and yeah she's
come a long way - she looks a lot more
like a legitimate queen of Westeros than
Khal Drogo's child bride in this group
of photos we also have a brand new shot
with her standing up talking to Varys in
front of the throne here it looks like
she's getting some counsel from him and
it's hard to speculate exactly what
would be happening I expect that
relations are going to break down in
this meeting because John won't bend the
knee so he may have like made a point
here something that gives her pause
where she has to ask Varys something
about its validity or what he knows
about it either way there's not much in
these photos that changes what I
speculate will happen I mean Tyrion
specifically left out the part about
bending the knee when he wrote John in
the last episode and this is probably
because he figured no one would agree to
him coming so for that reason and
remember Tyrion and Daenerys don't
really have any idea that John was
interested in coming
dragonglass in the first place this may
be what the next photo is hinting at we
see Tyrion outside talking to whom I am
presuming is John now we can tell this
is at a different time because Tyrion is
wearing something different but this
exchange should be really interesting as
Tyrion tries to appeal to Jon's
reasonable side we all know Jon has that
reasonable side but as this plays out
it's really not very likely that they're
going to come to an agreement of any
kind early on but overall I think Jon
came south looking for an ally in
Daenerys will probably push the issue of
him pledging fealty and by that I mean
like not an equal working relationship
you know and this is going to back Jon
into a corner Daenerys will want to show
her strength most likely and that's very
real like she has real strength she
doesn't necessarily meet Jon to
accomplish her goals and she's probably
not going to back off that position it's
basically like bending here we're done
here so if we look at their objectives
they're not the same at all Daenerys
wants to be recognized as the true queen
of Westeros and hold the Iron Throne and
John is worried about the White Walkers
approaching from the north in their
first meeting I don't think that either
will be very interested in the other
person's plan so this relationships
going to just take time to develop it
has to this is why the image of Varys
and Melisandre talking may be the most
interesting of all these photos she's
the only person at Dragonstone that
understands that the White Walkers are
the real threat and so she could be a
valuable ally to John and getting
Daenerys to see things as they are but
there's this problem that John's man
wants to kill her on sight like Davos is
obviously not going to drop his dislike
for her in a day so that things will
work out you know things are going to
get complicated plus we know Varys is
kind of adverse to the idea of magic in
red priests and priestesses based on
what's happened to him so that you know
it's a pretty interesting dynamic
although I do think that he sort of came
around in the Canberra situation but we
really don't know be on Dragonstone we
got a few images of other parts of
Westeros we
see Sansa and Littlefinger in the north
to me it looks like they're receiving
someone at Winterfell and at first I
thought this might be brand and then I
thought maybe Arya but it seems weird
like little fingers standing out to the
front like he's in front of Santa and
she's behind which he would think it
would be the other way around if one of
her siblings was there that could be
just reading too much into the photo I
don't know but in reality this could be
just about anyone showing up so let me
know in the comments what you guys think
Littlefinger is up to here I mean it
probably involves him doing something to
drive a wedge between Jon and Sansa but
who they are talking to doesn't seem
outright obvious to me you also have a
shot a Samwell at the Citadel so we
should be visiting there I mean there's
not much that we can tell from this he's
talking to someone that's probably
behind that desk that he's standing by
and then the last photo from this batch
is a very cool close-up of grey worm
getting ready to move on Casterly Rock
this really gives us a nice look at the
unsullied armor with that same
three-headed dragon adornment that we
saw on Hassan Dee and this could be the
Queen's justice here it's her payback
for what happened at sea we really don't
know the last photo of the entire group
is of Daenerys and she's turned fully
around on the staircase team we've seen
in the trailers it almost looks
different because this photo is so much
clearer but you can see she's wearing
the same clothes and that you can see
that three-headed dragon pan that she
has on her chest as I mentioned my
thoughts are that she'll be meeting John
one-on-one here and that he'll make a
more compelling plea for his cause he
may have to try to get back in on her
good side of [ __ ] went down when they
met in the throne room but at the end of
the day I think he can plant a seed here
and they'll still have a distance to go
until their goals line up now I got some
flack in the comments about saying that
John won't Bend the need is Daenerys
when they meet and honestly I still
stand by that I'm not sure people aren't
looking at the whole picture or what but
when she tells Tyrion she expects him to
bend the knee it translates to him
putting the north behind her cause
his house his name all of his men that
followed him we know that her cause is
that she wants to rule Westeros I give
to show a lot of leeway because it's
enjoyable to watch but if he comes to
pledges to her I will have any hard time
accepting that it would mean setting
aside what he was just arguing with in
the Great Hall that the real threat was
north of the wall and it just wouldn't
make sense for him to do it on the other
side if she's just all like oh this
White Walkers I mean these things sound
really scary that's terrible count me in
and then she just goes out there and
helps them take out the White Walkers
that would be equally annoying she spent
the entire series becoming a queen and
her aim is to take back the throne for
her family so with all that in mind I
think there'll be a huge roadblock here
she'll need convincing he'll need to
make his case and it's just going to be
like that and she'll be making a serious
offensive strike against the Lannisters
when great grey worm hit Casterly Rock
with his unsullied so she's got other
things going on too the bit in the
description about Cersei returning a
gift is pretty curious I don't think
there's any chance that she's going to
give back any of the three prisoners we
expect your honors delivering two
hurricanes landing at least not alive so
this could have some real implications
I'm guessing she'll choose a long and
torturous death for ilaria and tyene
because of Marcella
so that leaves Yara and things aren't
looking good if your last name is gray
Julian you prefer to capital right now I
don't think you're on has no love for
her so yeah she's kind of out on a limb
there it should be interesting to see
how that whole meeting goes down we did
get any new photos from King's Landing
but we see in the trailers that you know
your arms definitely gonna arrive in
this episode with his gifts and we know
that the episode description says that
Cersei will be returning something so
we'll just have to wait and see we also
get from the description that Jamie
learns from his mistakes and you know
it's thinking about this when I was
writing the script and I mean there's so
many of them I don't know if this is
tactically or if this is
with his sister or yeah so let's discuss
it in the comments see what you guys
think hopefully you see a little bit now
why John won't bend the knee and if I'm
wrong I'm wrong I'm a I could always be
wrong that's not good let's not confuse
it it's just it doesn't make any sense
so I hope it doesn't happen I hope we
get to see a reasonable story develop
between these two are you more excited
about John meeting Daenerys or are you
hoping that he'll see the dragons and
what happens with that let me know
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel I've been
doing a full schedule of Game of Thrones
and I will be continuing to do that on
top of all the other videos I make so
check back soon thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon